-How are you, Mj?
-I am good.
I'm good, I'm good.
-I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm happy I'm here, too.
-This is a fantastic show
created by Ryan Murphy,
and it's sort of --
Oh, it's about the
underground ball culture i
New York in the '80s and '90s.
And for those who don't know
what that is, lay it out.
-Okay. Well, I mean, the
ball culture, ballroom culture
that really started in
New York City,
underground ballroom culture -
it's a place where a lot o
LGBT community members --
they go to.
They find refuge.
They find comfort.
They get to be
who they truly want to be.
And they just get to live
their lives completely
and find the people that the
feel most comfortable with
to raise them,
lift them up in ways
that they never thought before
-And you're from Newark?
-Yes, I am.
-And did you find your way -
Did you come into the city
Did you find your way
into this culture?
-Yeah. It was kind of crazy.
I mean, I was 14 years old
in high school.
I went to a school called
Arts High in Newark, New Jersey.
And that's actually where
my housefather
at the time found me.
I was walking, I think, one of
his fashion shows
or just a fashion show in
general at school,
and he saw me.
He was like,
"That's my daughter."
And I actually met him through
a couple of my friends
before I had even seen him
They were immersed in
the ballroom scene
before I had even gotten
hip to it.
And it just sprawled out
from there.
-So, for those
who don't the terminology,
explain what a
housefather or a housemother is.
-Okay, so, a housefather
or housemother --
those are the people
that upkeep the house
that they've created.
So, for example,
the House of LaBeija --
they'll have a housefather
and a housemother
to be the kind of,
like, matriarch and the monarc
of the house and make sure
that everything is okay,
the kids are learning.
They'll teach
some voguing lessons.
They'll give them
everything that they need
that their other parents
wouldn't give them.
-What is the first lesson
of voguing?
What is the first thing
you learn?
-Um...hmm.
I mean, there's so many things
that you can learn.
You can learn duck-walking
But we're not gonna
do that right now
'cause I got some heels on
-Okay, great.
-But there's, like,
hand performance
and there's many elements to i
that you have to incorporate
in order to do it all.
-And it seems like precision i
a very important part of it?
-Yes. You can't sloppy.
I remember, when I was younger
my housefather at the time -
I snuck out and I went
to a rehearsal at Ripley-Grier
And he said,
"Let's see what you got."
And I got up there and I did -
It was called fem voguing.
And I got up there and I did
a complete messy job.
And he was like, "What is that?"
He's like, "What is that?"
And I said,
"It was voguing, right?"
He said, "No."
Neno, who was
one of his housesons --
he was like,
"Show her what it's all about.
And I was like,
"All right, cool."
-It seems like the
underground ball culture -
pretty open with
their feedback, yes?
-Yes. very much so.
-Nobody, like, ever keeps thei
opinion to themselves.
-No, but you have to have that
It's a space of honesty.
It's a space of comfort.
So they all let you have i
right then and there.
They will read you down,
and you're like,
"Mm-hmm, thank you."
-And you play
a housemother on the show.
-I do, I do.
-Who did you
draw inspiration from?
Was there anyone in your lif
that you were --
-My mama.
-Yeah?
She comes with me
every single place I go.
And she was always that pillar
for me to look up to,
alongside many LGBT members that
were very, very strong
in my life, but she was that one
that kept me sturdy
and kept me sane.
And she just made sure
I kept on the right path.
-You got to bring your mom t
the Golden Globes last year.
-I did!
-How was it?
Was she excited?
Did you have a great time?
-Oh, yeah.
We were very excited.
We were in the bathroom doing,
like, a movie number,
singing in the mirror
and everything.
It was epic. It was epic.
-Were there any people you wer
particularly excited to see?
-So many people.
But I remember seeing
Bradley Cooper sitting, like
right across from me,
and I was like, "Oh, my God!
That's Bradley Cooper!
Is he gonna see me?"
-You also went to the Met Ball
for the first time this year
looking like a million dollars
-Yeah. Yes, I did.
-And that is another incredibl
night for people-watching.
-Did you get your --
Did you get the full experience?
Did you get see the people
you wanted to see
that night, as well?
-I got to see every single
last person I wanted to see.
And, more so than anything
I felt so included and accepted.
I walked up and shook
Anna Wintour's hand
and I was like,
"You're Anna Wintour.
Oh, okay."
And then the next person
was Lady Gaga,
and she just grabbed me
and she said
some really, really, wonderful
like, encouraging words,
and I cried a lot.
-That's alright.
It's a very good pla--
They always say,
"If you need a good cry,
go to the Met Ball."
-Go to the Met Ball,
and you will cry your eyes out
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here
and congratulations
on everything.
Mj Rodriguez, everybody.